regardless of politics I think we can
all agree that those photos of Ronald
Reagan driving around his ranch in the
80s are pretty iconic his dope jeeps are
what make the shot but try to drive one
of those now and the maintenance and odd
mechanics won't make it easy that's why
I was happy to try out a new scrambler
of sorts the one made by two mechanics
in Wyoming who started a company called
legacy power wagons together they've
been building this type of wagon for
more than 40 years
I wanted to see if this Jeep drives as
great as it looks so I took it out to
the orange groves near Ojai California
both on the road and up the side of the
neighboring Hills
now since this aluminum truck is so
light at only 3,200 pounds and capable
with more than a dozen variations of
high neutral or low drive for both front
and rear wheels it can handle everything
from boulders and sand to rivers and
snow
when he put it into first low gear it
practically walks itself down the hill
like a big animal crawling over the
rocks this $150,000 new old truck packs
a 240 horsepower Boeing military diesel
engine housed in a badger tank and it
gets a massive 420 foot-pounds of torque
basically right from the get-go
the one I drove is a six-speed Automatic
but you can choose to have a manual
version as well it's the ideal estate
car or safari wagon
feel like you're in the same animal that
is like
have to drive it but it's not great for
highway driving or cruising around town
it's just too loud and bumpy you'll
arrive looking like a tornado blew you
in but it does feel pretty amazing to
drive like you're in the war rig with
furiosa herself it rumbles like a tank
and is towering Lehigh with massive
brakes and a steering wheel that goes
all over the place enough to give to
forge a minefield did I mention the fuel
efficiency in this thing is more than 30
miles per gallon
that's better than plenty of luxury
sedans and sports cars better yet the
scrambler comes with a soft top and
totally customizable seat options for
the rear and everything inside including
the seats and the radio are treated to
be waterproof interested the waiting
list is a year long and it takes nearly
another year to build legacy makes only
10 or so of these a year and they sell
out really quickly so you'll have to be
patient but that's ok good things take
time
especially good all american-made things
Reagan would be proud